or to other news and at least four
children and an adult have been injured
in a knife attack in France it happened
in a playground in the town of on sea in
the French Alps police say the attacker
is a refugee from Syria Nadine barber
has more
[Applause]
a helicopter lands by Lake annasie in
Southeastern France a site of natural
beauty that's now cordoned off from
being treated as a crime scene
eyewitnesses say a man stabbed several
children at a playground in a park here
this video allegedly shows the attacker
being approached by adults in the park
[Music]
he's said to be a Syrian Christian who
received Refugee status in Sweden
earlier this year all the victims were
taken by helicopter to a nearby hospital
this man saw the attack unfolding
all of a sudden one of the mums says run
there's a guy stabbing everybody all
along the lake he stabbed some children
I'm a bit surprised but I keep going and
I see the guy coming towards me the
police are about five or ten meters
behind him and they can't catch up with
him
the attacker then reportedly stabbed an
elderly man before being shot by police
as news of the incident came through
politicians in the National Assembly
stopped to observe a minute's silence
Elizabeth born the French prime minister
and her interior Minister Gerald darmana
then headed to anisee
overwhelmed by this hateful and
Indescribable act when children are
involved I think it particularly affects
us deep inside
while President macron has denounced
what he calls an absolutely cowardly
attack tweeting the nation is in shock
our thoughts go out to the victims their
families and the Emergency Services
the motive for the attack is still being
investigated Nadine barber Al Jazeera